this video is about a forbidden
technique in Python the twin snake
sacrifice shoots storing mutable or
non-hashable things in sets and
dictionaries
normal sets and dicks use hashing
meaning when you want to check if an
element is in there you use the
element's hash to pick the exact index
where the element would go if it was
present so you can just check that one
location instead of checking every
location it's kind of like when you go
to the grocery store and need to find
the milk you don't walk through every
aisle you just go straight to the
refrigerated section and if it's not
there then they're out no need to check
the rest of the store
but hashes are necessarily based on the
state of an object in order to make
hashes be different for as many
different objects as possible hash
collisions are allowed they just degrade
performance like if the grocery store
made the whole store refrigerated then
you'd have to fall back to searching
every aisle to find the milk
but if hashes are based on object State
then mutating the object would probably
change its hash so if you went to go
find it later you'd look in the wrong
place for that reason the usual wisdom
is that you shouldn't make mutable
things hashable python tries to enforce
this by defining a Dunder hash for your
classes by default but not defining the
hash if you define an equals function
in practice this is a solid 6 out of 10
solution but realistically python can't
do any better it can't read your mind
and there's no default that would suit
every case so if you have an opinion
about whether or not your type should be
hashable then either Define the hash
yourself or set it to none but sometimes
you just want a set of mutable or
unhashable things so what do you do you
could use a list or create your own
mapping or set type that stores data in
a list but this is not the Forbidden
technique the problem is looking up
elements becomes incredibly slow because
you lose that constant time look up that
hashing provides you're falling back to
checking every aisle in the store for
the milk
instead let's take advantage of a key
property of every python object its
identity
every python object hashbull or not
mutable or not has an integer ID that's
guaranteed to be both unique and
constant for the duration of its
lifetime you can access this ID by using
the built-in ID function IDs can be
reused after one object is garbage
collected its old id could be reassigned
to a new object but as long as an object
is alive the ID is an immutable hashable
value that uniquely determines the
object I hope you see where I'm going
with this so what we're going to do is
make our own mapping and set types that
internally never hash the object itself
but instead hash the ID of the object in
our mapping type we'll still use a plain
old dict but we'll map the identity of a
key to its key value pair again the ID
of a key is just an INT it's perfectly
fine to use as a key of a dictionary
regardless of whether or not the key
itself is hashable
the result of looking up an ID is a key
value pair storing the key in addition
to the value ensures that the key isn't
garbage collected and that the key's ID
won't get reused by another object as
long as this mapping exists getting an
item now just looks up the ID of the key
in the dict and Returns the value
setting an item just Maps the key ID to
the key value pair and deleting an item
just deletes the ID of the key from the
map
there are a few other functions here but
they're pretty straightforward and we
take advantage of the collections
mutable mapping ABC to fill in the rest
of the usual dictionary interface like
get pop and so on
our set type is similar we keep a
plainal dict of value IDs to values
again we're storing the value in
addition to its ID to prevent values
from being garbage collected while the
set is still alive
adding an element to the set means
mapping its ID to its value discarding
an element means popping its ID from the
map and checking if an element is in the
set is just checking if its ID is a key
in the dictionary once again there are a
few other pretty simple functions and we
use collections Mutual set abstract Base
Class to fill out the rest of the usual
set interface
and there we go we can now create a list
which is not hashable put it in our
mapping or set no problem even mutate it
in between and we can still look it up
no problem mutating the list doesn't
change its ID
great so what's the downside
the downside is that when I look up an
element I need to use the exact same
object not just an equal one
compared to a normal set if I add 257 in
then add int of float of 257 in the set
just has one element 257.
but if I use the ID set the same code
would add in two copies of 257 because
the two 257s although equal are
different python objects that have
different IDs
it is still a set and it does filter
duplicates but in order to be considered
a duplicate you have to add in the exact
same object twice this can be especially
confusing for small object types like
ins and strings or for types where it's
not clear whether it's operations mutate
the object in place or return a new one
back to you I highly discourage using
these types with ID mapping or ID set
and this potential for confusion is the
reason this is forbidden python
knowledge but if you're certain your
objects will be stored and looked up
using the exact same object then you
might find this trick to come in handy
I take no responsibility for the
criticism you get in code review if you
actually try this though it's forbidden
knowledge for a reason
thanks to me myself and I for sponsoring
myself in addition to making esoteric
and questionable python content on
YouTube I also run a software Consulting
business if you have a project at your
company that you think needs some
outside eyes check us out at mcoding.io
and of course thank you to my patrons
and donors for supporting the channel
I appreciate the support and I'm glad
you find my videos useful don't forget
to slap that like button an odd number
of times and I'll see you in the next
one